I'm at County stamp down and a pair of
electric green gripper socks and that
are not my own you tell whoever the
you want because all is lost
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite all-time Thomas you guys are
going to absolutely love her it's an
honor to bring up to the stage
got a note short necklace called lady
dynamite please keep it going
whispering congratulations on being here
tonight there's it's so hard to live in
Los Angeles people are working so hard
Eveline LA but in this country that's
all we talk about what are you working
on these days what's going on with you
what's on the next page for you what's
it what's it what's coming up for you
where to go to what are you working on
oh oh I'm done yeah I finished early
oh it's all so scary huh see what do you
do what do you do for a living and I
often say that I'm bookkeeper which I am
I do my own QuickBooks I've been audited
by the IRS five times turns up they owed
me 25 bucks couple I am I may be
eccentric but I save my receipts and uh
[Music]
anyways um the reason I saying what
bookkeepers cuz once I was on a flight
from JFK to LAX and I made the mistake
of saying what I did and the woman went
into a PTSD stream-of-consciousness
monologue the worst experience I ever
had in my whole life was that a comedy
club we had to sit through this man
bombing Verna our and it was so painful
I will never go see stand-up comedy
again well we are sorry that you
experienced that with our services if
there's any way we can win back your
business in fact I'd love to set you up
with 20 free tickets to a comedy show as
you guys know they're pretty easy to
come by
um so uh defensively I asked her what
she did for a living of course and she
explained that she was an employee of a
little company called Cirque de Soleil
as a clown
a clown I have dated a clown
before and I have sat through five
performances of a clown as Christ figure
clown crucified red rubber nose audience
armed with water balloons as to scream
Jew while throwing them at said clown
Christ if you want to talk about the
deep discomfort of the arts dive in my
only regret is that I wish I had paid to
see those shows but I was I was on the
guest list so um I was uh I couldn't
work for a while I took about a year and
a half off of work because I went mental
and um I don't know if anyone here is
thinking of suicide don't do it it's not
the season for late fall and most people
you don't think about doing it if you
think of it you know every once in a
while just kind of feeling sorry for
yourself like well the stewardess won't
give me the whole candle turbulence I
want to live but
I had told a friend of mine um hey heads
up if ever I start talking too fast
about wanting to get into the touch of
the Pope or some other ethical authority
put me in a purple van and drive it a
doggy daycare because I need to be
boarded for the weekend mental illness
runs in my family and it drops it about
40 years old and that's what happened my
friend drove me to the psych ward and um
I had my interview with the psychiatrist
and he asked me uh you know why here I
said well I have a plan I'm gonna put in
come alone okay great um what are the
mitigating circumstances well I just you
know just I just
every moment is unbearable and so I just
worried that I'm gonna I don't feel safe
by myself like I'm gonna do something
like I'm gonna hurt myself I know I will
and I know I will and I'll be a mess I
just don't do that to other okay and
they said well what do you do for a
living man
no response totally chill event and um
went on typing on his laptop uh he
seemed a little distracted and there is
a some sound coming from his machine and
I get it you know I get bored at work
right now while I'm doing this story I'm
actually watching a turtle
I eat Asst on a whimp video hey it just
uh it's nice to just get a break
anyways so he was doing something on his
laptop turned his around to me and he
said is this you and he had YouTubed me
and uh it was me obviously with a lot
more makeup and much better material and
he said oh I had I had to make sure that
I you weren't having a grandiose
delusion
[Music]
since when is it psychosis to somehow
claim that you're interacting with the
entertainment industry it's not like I
said I was Richard Pryor and if I had
claimed to be one of the best comedians
of this past century and a black man and
deceased at that and been able to do
anything from his 1979 special in Long
Beach
well how wonderful would that have been
but the last last laugh was on me
because he put me on a mood stabiliser
whose primary side effects are cognitive
making it almost impossible to think or
talk no own or should I say Oh No
ah few days later I was doing a gig and
by myself in Chicago bleeding and I'd
lost all my identification and was
making this noise uh about an hour
before showtime and I called my mother
and said ha ha ha ha
honey somehow get to the airport go to
Delta priority tell them you are gold
medallion and tell them about your
website and I did what my mother told me
and I got a first class upgrade because
I was just batshit crazy enough to have
that many points and ended up taking it
yet almost two years off work and oh
just I always like to say this I was so
scared of taking up time off work
especially just in case anyone found out
you know oh god what if somebody found
out oh oh god this is what happens if
somebody finds out I was in the psych
ward and a woman came up to me and said
um hi um I know you I'm a therapist here
but I I don't know you personally but I
have friends in the comedy circles and
Joao de la Rosa he's out of the stress
factory and New Brunswick New Jersey you
do you ever played it you know oh you
should it's a great surprising because I
would think that I mean not that I would
I would never I would never tell this is
completely confidential and I would
never I would never dawn
I'm a County stamped down and a pair of
electric green gripper socks that are
not my own you tell whoever the you
want because all is lost but I uh went
out back to work and I just yeah just I
can't do as much today I used to and I
got all this from this one fellow
coworker you know ya heard what happened
in Chicago sheesh
yeah there's a real man site I owe them
a lot of money
I missed like six shows us a thermal
thermal mess yeah I'd never done that
I've never missed a show I'd I had a
temperature of 475 degrees out of the
temperature of a fully charred pork chop
I did a full 90 minutes lost control my
bowels to standing ovations you've got
to make those laughs yeah I
guess I was just worried you know I
wasn't able to think or talk and it
might not be as funny as I'd hoped
yeah calm has got to be funny it's got
to be funny to everybody it's not just a
funny it's hot comedy you gotta check it
out I test my I went to China this
year I was not welcome it was extremely
uncomfortable I did not have a visa but
I spent three months there I translated
all my jokes into facial expressions
guess who has a tour that gets you
province that's awesome man so you
remember you're scared of doing a
certain you know type of game no
challenge I was doing a pop-up open mic
at a live birth and uh yeah of course
the moms distracted but uh you don't
just just to be there for baby's first
laughs you know I know I always do this
closer with a younger crowd sit please
don't take it I've been doing this is
the late 80s it kind of pissed me off
because I see people doing it it's like
I got this on tape
but here's the closer's oh peekaboo
is yours mana yeah basically copyrighted
the entire human experience that's
awesome yeah I guess you know I just I
can't I can't be as ambitious as the
once was you know so uh like right
before tonight's show I looked in the
reflection of my diet coke can and I
said hey hey hey hey hey hey kid I want
to see 20%
if not five so what who cares it doesn't
even matter
thank you guys so much
you